hi I'm Farrah and like Taylor Swift I
enjoy cooking a lot so I decided to try
her three favorite dinner party recipes
[Music]
on a scale of 1 to 10 I think I rate my
cooking abilities as maybe a solid 7 in
my early 20s I was definitely more of
like a 2 3 so I'm definitely not like
ready to go on any type of cooking show
but I think I could make a solid meal
for friends if they were to come over so
Taylor Swift's three favorite dinner
party recipes are a magar Tain's
spaghetti and meatballs Nigella Lawson's
Mughal chicken and Jamie Oliver's
fajitas with mole a sauce for the most
part all of these dishes were relatively
inexpensive to make especially the Vicki
does it was there's a lot of produce in
it with the peppers so for Jamie
Oliver's fajita recipe I followed it by
the book for the most part at just
involved getting chicken Tomatoes dark
chocolate for the mole a sauce two
different types of peppers and onion
tortillas Greek yogurt for the like the
topping which was really interesting to
me because I think I usually think of
sour cream as like that kind of topping
but Greek yogurt it's a little bit
healthier and cilantro to top everything
off
okay so I just cut the peppers into
strips and now I get to cut this onion
which is not my favorite part so I
always cheer up my name's make my eyes
so irritated but here we go
we made it through this onion cutting
with minimal tears so here's why I'm
changing up this recipe a little bit it
says to marinate the vegetables and
chicken together but I'm gonna do it
sadly because I have a vegetarian friend
and I'm separate and so I have to
believe that Taylor also has vegetarian
friends so maybe she also does this
either way I'm gonna do it I hope it's
those who be cooking like this seems a
little key right now I was worried about
dumping all that chocolate in it that's
to see how it tastes
I've never had this particular and any
sauce before but you know what - it's as
I've said I'm sure it's delicious
Taylor Swift always wrote alright here's
the final result
it looks pretty tasty I'm excited to see
how the sauce turned out oh my gosh this
is actually so delicious I was worried
the sauce would be too chocolatey
because it seems like the recipe called
for a lot of that dark chocolate but
everything is so so good
all the flavors blend together really
well so I'm gonna go eat the rest of
this dish I thought would be the easiest
to recreate was inna Garten spaghetti
and meatballs only because I cooked
spaghetti so many times in my life that
I was pretty confident that I knew how
to boil noodles I followed everything
exactly as the recipe except I did not
use ground beef I use ground turkey and
I think that was something that
concerned me initially when making the
meatballs was because I wasn't sure if
they were good it tastes differently or
like cook the same now just like you is
not
it worked really well
[Music]
chopping up these four onions white
onions but my eyes are still so
irritated
[Music]
[Applause]
what probably gonna taste
okay there is the final result I think
it looks beautiful I'm proud of myself
alright I'm gonna take the first bite
yeah this is legit Wow the meatballs are
so tender and flavorful and the sauce is
just really kick-ass way better than a
jar my dog wants some but I think
probably the most difficult part for
that dish was creating the meatballs but
it wasn't even that difficult it was
just putting them in oil I was a little
nervous about it no if I had done
something wrong and they would just like
not turn out good or if I'd overcook
them but in the end it ended up being
very very simple and really delicious
I'm about to start making Taylor Swift's
third dinner party recipe one of our
favorites
and it's the Mukai chicken but look at
all these ingredients I'm a little
intimidated because this is way more
than the other recipes but I'm feeling
pretty confident myself so I think I
could handle it I think I spent a good
half an hour not exaggerating standing
in front of the spice rack at the store
like looking at all of them and trying
to find the ones that she used is it was
just like a whole thing and because just
the shopping trip part was so complex I
was like oh man this recipe is gonna be
complex in my head only because I have
never attempted to cook curry before
okay so I just killed some garlic with a
knife they don't own a proper garlic
press but in the article Taylor said
that owning one was game-changing for
her and as someone who was also born in
1989 I think it's time for me to own one
too because killing garlic is kind of a
chore but you just got to do what Taylor
Swift does I also don't own a food
processor so we're gonna see if this
magic bullet can make this into a paste
like the recipe says so fingers crossed
it all works out otherwise I'm gonna
have to grind it myself by hand okay I
think it works pretty well we're just
gonna roll with it
at the almonds and the water next so I
think that should help it become more
paste like I used a whole bunch of
spices that were in the recipe the only
two things that I changed a little bit
differently I could not find cinnamon
sticks at the grocery store I looked
everywhere like I said it was in the
spice aisle for what seemed like an hour
and a half but I ended up just saying
forget it I guess they don't have whole
cinnamon sticks here I have powdered
cinnamon at my apartment that's just
gonna have to do the second thing was I
was also 99% sure that I had bought
cardamom pods which took me a really
long time to find in the store as well
and when I got home suddenly I couldn't
find them they just disappeared it
seemed like I went back through all my
grocery bags could not find them later
to find out that they had like slipped
in this crack behind my coffee machine
so I found them like after I had already
cooked everything so I had the intention
of using them but they were hiding from
me at the time of cooking still use
cinnamon just a different style of
cinnamon and sadly cannot use the
cardamom pods because they were hiding
from me
[Applause]
all right it's all done being cooked
only took me two hours to make so we'll
see if it's worth it
this is good yes so I think upfront the
moogle I chicken was probably the most
expensive only because the price of the
spices if you don't have that variety of
spices in your kitchen already and you
have to go out and buy all the different
types of spices for the curry
specifically that can add up but once
you have those spices in your kitchen
they will last you a long time so if you
wanted to make it again like you already
have most of the ingredients and then
the recipe that actually ended up being
the hardest was Nigella Lawson's Mughal
a chicken in a sense that it took
probably the longest to put together but
in the end was probably one of the most
delicious dishes the dish that was
hands-down the best tasting was I think
the spaghetti and meatballs specifically
because the meatballs weren't dry at all
I'm gonna use like a controversially
gross word but they were very moist and
just flavorful and it really
complimented the sauce and spaghetti
really well but a very close second was
Nigella Lawson's the Mughal eyed chicken
that had just so many good flavors and
the chicken was just very tender and the
curry sauce was like both sweet and
salty at the same time and it's all this
really good
which dish would I cook for Taylor Swift
herself I think she would be wowed by
how well I could cook the spaghetti
meatballs because I impressed myself and
I've cooked spaghetti a million times
but for some reason this spaghetti was
just next-level
it was really interesting trying someone
else's favorite recipes especially
because this is Taylor Swift and I feel
like she's the queen of cooking and
baking just kitchen stuff in general and
to attempt these recipes was a little
bit of a challenge for me but it ended
up being a lot of fun I have not made
any of these a second time but I
definitely plan to I just need an
occasion Taylor Swift invite me over
I'll cook you one of your favorite meals
for your birthday so overall I'm really
glad I attempted these recipes because I
feel like I learned a lot and I got to
try new things which is really good so
if you like hosting dinner parties or
you just want to feed family and friends
because you're a nice person definitely
try some of Taylor Swift's favorites and
if you want to read more in detail about
my experience you can check out in the
description below the link to the post
[Music]